[Music]
before I get into how Manhattan College
is using firebase to develop its student
mobile app I like to provide some
background Manhattan College and how its
how journey has been evolving over the
past decade a lot of things have
happened over the college that it was
very important to share but allowed us
to to evolve our journey here the glance
Manhattan College student app was a big
opportunity for change here before we
get into talking about though I'll share
some background of our cloud adoption
within how I'll talk about how
influenced web development at Manhattan
College and then another thing we also
were talking about how we evolved the
app and what led to how we picked native
app I'll then get into talking a little
bit about Google assistant which was the
idea of a personal assistant was always
near and dear to her house arts it was
part of the visioning of the native app
but that's allowed us to use more of the
Google Cloud product and I'll touch a
little bit on how we're using data
studio using data from the app in
conjunction with bigquery will then
follow with question and answers
Manhattan College has the best of both
worlds it's a residential campus it's
pretty tiny
it has about 4,000 students it's five
six goals school of arts liberal arts
school of education and Health School of
Business those are located on the upper
campus along with part of the School of
Science and down below
sure enough here is lower campus and
that houses the School of Engineering
part of the school science and also the
research and learning center where my
group and most of IT is located you
notice that it's very close to
Manhattan there's actually a the end of
the subway line just to the east of the
campus
so the Shu subway stops right down there
and it's about a 35 minute ride into
Manhattan
so it's very close and yeah it's pretty
small and college is small I work in the
lower campus is about 4/10 of a mile
walk up to the entrance to the college
it probably takes about 10 minutes so
sort of densely packed there's been a
lot of changes that have happened over
the college over the last 10 years that
are sort of part of relevant to our
cloud journey there have been changes to
the physical infrastructure the college
converted from mostly a commuter campus
to a residential one probably around 19
or around 2012 with the addition of more
dormitories and there's been a lot of
master planning going on the most recent
one was the addition of a sari pointer
was the building of a student Commons in
2014 and with the introduction of that
there were a lot of other things that
had happened the college in terms of
branding we also got a new president
around 2009 also some new people and
that's when a lot of things started
changing including our adoption with
cloud
oops sorry
I'm going to describe a little bit about
the group that I work in Manhattan
college is of course a higher education
place our information technology
services department is a structured
similar to life and other colleges I
noticed that we were front door of a
number of people here at this
presentation from higher ed so we're
part of information technology services
which is headed by our CIO Jake
Holmquist who's here today we also have
four groups of which mine is one or my
group is web applications it was
formerly called web and collaboration a
lot of these names have changed a little
bit over time we have enterprise
architecture and they're responsible for
security networking and well what used
to be the data center and we have a
director here Rob Moran we have
enterprise application group which is
really responsible for our ERP system
our enterprise resource planning system
and all our business applications we
have client services and operations
which handles our helpdesk and also
knowledgebase Service Catalog
and in operations are all public labs
and then my group which is involved in
anything related to web pretty much
changes over time the whole IT
organization is like 22 full-time people
so it's pretty small but everybody has
to wear a lot of different hats and so
we work pretty closely my group works
very closely with most of the other
groups in addition because we are
involved in the web we work very closely
with marketing and communication in
particularly now the office of web
communications now man at college need
to mention here that Manhattan College
received a 2017 cloud Leadership Award
from Eni co-operative services it was
presented at the EDUCAUSE conference in
Pittsburgh or Philadelphia last fall and
they got this for their involvement in
advancing hybrid infrastructure and
platform as service cloud architectures
so our information technology services
has done a lot in terms
of using cloud and in particular Google
cloud a little bit about my group we're
basically a developing group we have
right now we have four people we used to
have three people again we're involved
in all things web in the about twenty
years ago when the web started we were
involved a lot of other kind of lot of
things and about ten years ago or so ago
marketing and communications took more
role in that and web app took the and IT
took more of a support role we also work
a lot with emerging technologies and
trying out new things and trying to use
them to develop custom applications we
because of the type of materials we
worked with we've sort of been adopting
an agile and DevOps culture and cloud
computing we use a lot of open source
software arts art I always laugh because
we sort of have a frugal mindset because
a lot of the things that my group does
eventually gets replaced by a product
that comes out and so a lot of the stuff
that we're doing we feel like we're
throwing it away all the time so
whenever we do things we try to develop
our things for reuse and that's a good
thing now because not with API is and
everything is sort of all fits into the
model then I want to talk about
Manhattan's journey in the decade of the
cloud decade a mobile and and the whole
approach I would have been had college
for like 20 years and for the first 10
we basically started the web and
everything it seemed like not much was
happening where we were in the era of
web one at one point oh you know you had
your your web server people did stuff
whatever and then about 10 years of web
2o started to come into play and
everything became more intuitive people
started contributing information and
banks but that was also I think when a
lot of this and everything as the
service started we started to see a lot
of software as a service being
introduced the first one in that case
would be
Gmail okay and eventually but most of
those things are all services that are
delivered over the internet rather than
provided locally or on site so the thing
has been growing over the past 10 years
or evolving today especially in higher
ed we're seeing a lot of adopting the
best of read applications so rather than
having everything from one vendor we're
we're adopting a bunch of products from
a lot of different vendors and there
that president presents a lot of
integration challenges so the role that
we play is quite different so here's
sort of a simplified timeline of
Manhattan college and its involvement
with the Google cloud and again I
concentrated on the last 10 years
because that's when we started our using
our first software as a service and that
was Gmail that was pretty revolutionary
at the time we're probably one of the
first sets of colleges to introduce that
that was part of the G suite formerly
called Google Apps for Education and so
we started using a lot Google products
calendar Docs forums sheets in addition
we've always used for web the Google
search Google Maps Google Analytics
another big thing that we've sort of
more recently adopted was across the
campus was Google Drive but rather than
the last 10 years I think the key
defining point for the college in terms
of moving to the cloud was in the
timeframe of 2014 to 2016 there were a
lot of things that happened in the
college that just sort of make it all
this gave us opportunities to do this
was basically what we call Google cloud
phase 1 when Rob's group the enterprise
architecture group introduced a virtual
machine as a service so what that
entailed was migrating a lot of the web
applications over to the little cloud
into the compute play for him and also
at that time the college was going
through a rebranding effort for their
websites
and part of that involved us providing
web servers and rather than hosting them
in our data center they were now hosted
in the cloud on Google cloud so that was
and that was with also high availability
load balancing that so it was a bit that
was a big success for us eventually that
evolved more into Google's cloud base to
what we term the hybrid data center
where the database was left in our data
center and the other parts of the system
were out in the Google cloud and that
was facilitated by the introduction of
site to site VPN between the data center
and the clouds now he actually had two
parts of the system running in different
places or connected and so we've had our
first launch of our enterprise resource
planning system in the cloud in around
2017
so our CEO it was very very into cloud
and advancing cloud and we had a cloud
first strategy became part of our annual
goals starting in 2016 and 2017 part of
the the it we're told basically no more
no more servers everything that we get
now any kind of service is deployed in
the cloud no new hardware so that's sort
of been the mandate a little tough to
handle from the beginning but it's all
ok now but everything has been working
well and we've been pretty successful
okay
so I'll talk a little bit about the web
technology landscape prior to 2014 and
how we used to develop our applications
and whatever we were pretty comfortable
and used a PHP based lamp sack which was
Linux as the operating system apache
HTTP server as a web server MySQL as a
relational database and PHP is the
scripting language and that was used for
most of our all our custom development
work but also for to run our website
which we were using open source Drupal
as our content management system
framework we eventually played with Lisa
used to self host that and eventually we
started moving that to a platform as a
service provider in 2014 2016 so we have
some experience with the cloud from that
that was a little tough on the other end
we had what we called my MC portal and I
don't know if some of you are younger
you might read when you were in college
you might recall the the portals that
your school used to have was basically
almost like a monolithic system of
little screen windows into a bunch of
different applications a lot of it was
connected by single sign-on that was
pretty difficult for us to to pull off
first of all we were we adopted a
open-source framework for that called
you portal but that was a java-based
stack they used Linux as the operating
system but it used at Apache Tomcat as
the web server and oracle database a
relational database for database and
then used Java so we only have a small
staff we had three people in it and only
like one of them was a really good
developer so we learned a lot doing that
we ran that for about three years but it
was pretty limited and in the ends you
know marketing and communication was
looking for something more of like
people can go in and have a WYSIWYG
editor enter content whatever so
eventually as part of the web branding
initiative we got rid of that and we've
just something different
so again a lot of things happen in 2014
to 2016 and I just say this was sort of
a defining period for us and especially
for the web and it was at fate was it
kismet was that serendipity everything
just sort of came together very nicely
everything was happening at the right
time the college was going through a
branding initiative for the websites in
which case we ended up with a vendor
hosted content management system we also
there were also a lot of campus master
plans plan planning and taking effect
the college had you recall that I show
the new student Commons with all that
there were they finally licensed a room
event scheduling system so we had now we
had a lot of calendars and stuff and all
this everything as a service was
maturing and and the best part for us
and for our adoption of firebase was we
got summer interns the college had a
jesper summer research program and prior
to that a lot of other departments
especially in science and engineering
we're hiring students to come up with a
project they wanted to work on and they
would fund it for the summer and
whatever so ITF took on what my group
took done two summer interns and we had
to come up with a project for them to do
so before I get into the start of the
firebase I'll have you use that we're
seeing a lot of shifting technologies
and development at this time our content
management system and the publishing
model was different the websites were
all developed through a vendor SAS
solution but what was happening here is
the web content from that system was
basically published out to web servers
sort of like a static website okay it
had and had hooks into to use fees and
widgets and things like that but a lot
of the stuff even whips PHP was
basically done behind the scenes and the
website was published out every night we
publish out every night but so that gave
us more opportunity to start working
with data integration via widgets and
fees and you know either in our Asus XML
format or more importantly the JSON
format which we've sort of adopted and
it's also part of how firebase works the
other end it was like the death of our
portal I don't know that was good or bad
in retrospect it was good but we still
sort of sort of a little fad they allow
that go and a lot of the work we had
done disappear there were certain parts
of the portal that were useful and one
of the things was what they had was a
you were able to search within a
Portland and Portland is basically one
of those windows whatever but you
basically would enter some mated
metadata about what was in the portlet
and a lot of that was used at the portal
lever level to help people find things
another thing that the portal always had
was a lot of quicklinks you were
starting to see a lot of these
everything as a service products out
there and this people were using the
portal as a place where people would
come and find all those different links
so it was basically just a list of links
but anyway for the searching people were
starting to see more looking at other
kinds of solutions because the portal
and get pulling it off is a very
difficult concept unless you really
license subversion from one of the big
vendors
but you're starting to see more
lightweight campus portals where people
are starting to say these other products
do their thing well they don't really
want like for example Google they don't
really want you pulling in your email
threads into piece and window in the
portal and pulling in your candle your
calendar stuff into another window of
the portal and pulling in your files and
looking at him with other one it
basically and I had its old interface
and so roll with the flow so but those
are some of the good features of the
portal that we like people like to keep
and again it was a big learning
experience for us it was open source
product we learned a lot about
developing code and contributing code
whatever so a big thing for for the new
and what they called an internet website
was a way of aggregating all these
campus testing services and to do that
and this is also happening in
conjunction at the same time that we
started developing a student app was a
way to aggregate these someplace so that
people could find the information and
and the approach we basically took was
you know defining things like pay my
bill things like that and it might be
embedded in some system but people would
search for you know pay my bill or
tuition or whatever or find in the final
exam schedule and they would find it
through this interface and for this we
use a search as a service product from L
go Lea now we get into developing the
glance MC student app and it was sort of
named like that because of how some of
the conditions we put on this
development so again our native Moodle
mobile app was a summer of 2015 student
project the students had to come up with
a project they started one day I came
back from vacations I here's you to
students it's like they need project so
at that time everybody wanted to develop
apps
okay well they came up with this word
cloud here and things that were hot at
the time were mobile discovery portal
lightweight digital search native
personal assistant the big thing was the
campus ID card okay well we call our
Jasper card Manhattan College I didn't
mention this is our the Jasper's so I'll
keep using the ID card and Jasper card
together but they've they basically
students basically carried their cart
their phones around all the time a lot
of times they were forgetting their
their paper ID card okay with all the
new buildings that were having they were
starting to use these optical scanners
to allow entry into the dorms and to the
athletic but gym and other places like
that so the students kept saying oh be
cool if we had our ID card on our phones
so all that was part of the visioning
for this student app so only had a
choice okay what are we gonna use for
the stack to develop this app at the
time you really had Apple you had
Android or we could develop a
cross-platform app they were at the time
of predominance of Apple devices on our
campus students might have had a phone
the ecosystem from Apple it could have
been like the laptop they had a phone
they had an iPad or whatever and the
students wanted to develop apps for
Apple felt that development was easier
there because they only had a couple
different sizes you had a couple life
different devices and they were all the
same okay so when you looked at Android
you had a lot of different phones you
had to worry about okay plus the
students that we had were also just
going instead junior year they really
hadn't had any
the college really didn't have a
computer science program at the time
those the students didn't have any kind
of training or anything but they just
felt comfortable developing for Apple
and they had I guess which had just come
out whatever for Android they had X they
had Android studio whatever and it
wasn't that well documents it at the
time were or the students felt so the
other choice was a cross-platform app
and they really couldn't get their hands
around that and the whole the whole idea
of thinking about that was tough so who
do you think won first half was an iOS
app okay with under the condition that
the next one would be Android so we had
these two students working all summer
they were funded as a as a gesture
research scholar at the time we've
employed them during the school years at
using campus employment work-study funds
and we also allowed them to learn we
provide a lot of training there's a lot
of self-study stuff learning that goes
on in my group we have a lot of
resources for that but anyway they ended
up with conceiving a a lightweight
motivic mobile app and they wanted
something where they can access
information on the go one of the
conditions from marketing communication
was that it complemented the new
websites that were coming out and they
also the college did not have its own
mobile app and didn't see a need for one
the websites were all responsive and
they felt that was that was good enough
but part of our justification for using
and they demote a mobile app was that we
would use features of the device like
maps and locations and also that we have
a digital campus ID card for use with
optical scanners okay and so the way we
worked it was this was kept as a student
developer product my group had oversight
and it sort of evolved a lot into some
healthy competition between the two
groups where we learned a lot from what
they were doing we also sort of met what
they're doing to make sure they're on
the right track but there's a lot of
competition
now I'm gonna get into developing the
glans student app and our app basics or
data modelling so the first thing they
had to do to come up with what they
wanted to put in is collect all the data
and then we need to have some place
where they could collect it where we
could see it so the the database quote
for that was basically a Google sheet
okay so they collected all the
information in a Google sheet a lot of
it was like Maps information coordinates
building codes the addresses things like
that this is a little bit more
sophisticated what they had at the point
but they had a lot of the stuff we had
from the portal were feeds you know
daily announcements News Twitter
features events events calendars lots of
events calendars with the with the new
system they had just put in place and so
they collected all in a Google sheet and
then they use this data when they
started developing the app so when the
app was released they basically wrote
all the stuff into the code okay we
released it a year later year and three
months later called glance em see
because glass meaning that we really
want didn't want them to incorporate
things in there that would get replaced
by an app that came out in the future
for example if our ear feed bender came
up with something and this College
adopted it we didn't want to have to
sort of throw away what we did so they
were supposed to keep more - you know
top-level type stuff here so we really
sit in at the same time we released the
Jasper pay at the college which allowed
people to pay for their meals and stuff
using their digital ID card and that's
become a big hit we also employed in
there this will be called the at a
glance search which was part of those
the aggregator Campus Services that we
show that we use on our internet portal
and we have a employee directory and all
those services in it and we also
incorporated a bunch of RSS and XML
feeds and a campus newspaper with time
we've added in geolocation Maps
integration so that's someone to see
what they looked up an employee it would
tell them if they click the location
icon it would tell you show their
location on a math and where they were
relative to the place where the first
was located same thing for the calendar
if the event
was happening someplace you'd see where
it was part of the problem with all that
too is we couldn't really use directions
because our campus has not mapped out
but by Google you notice there's a ring
road that runs around the campus on
upper campus with all these buildings
contained within so here come the
turning point now we've developed this
releases app for iOS and now we had to
worry about Android okay so we wanted to
match the features from the iOS app to
the Android one and then for future to
further development of the iOS app
there's a lot of things they want to
incorporate like favorites once they
found things that they'd like to search
they'd like to pin them so that they
have access to them all the time their
own favorites they wanted to have an
in-app campus ID card okay so the way we
deployed the campus ID card was through
Apple Wallet and we actually are using a
PCAST
PK pass file to do that which my group
had set up eventually when we released
this app for Android they coupled it
with a I think it was called a wallet
passes think from from Android so they
could get the campus ID card but if we
had an in-app gesture card then people
didn't need the other application
eventually one have access to authorized
data via authentication like people
wanted to see their course schedule on
the phone we had we still had a lot of
commuters or people to live off campus
and a lot of times if they he wanted to
go to our student information system
they have to go through a lot of
different steps to get to their schedule
and it was a format they couldn't read
on the phone okay so part of the problem
with all this now was the the app data
is actually on the device it was really
difficult to get something released into
the Apple Store it was a long process
and plus than anything we wanted to
change things there were things that
were always coming at somebody would say
can you incorporate this you know we
change calendars we change fees we do
whatever and so that was a an issue and
so we sort of saw the need for a mobile
backend as a service for this
and you know part of the whole thing was
this Apple app development takes a lot
of time so part of our agile methodology
let's rethink it and see what we need to
do next though the other choice was also
should we switch to a like react
something like react native to develop a
cross-platform app so now developing the
app states take to enter firebase so the
concept that students had at the time
was to use parse as a mobile backend and
then that was announced that they were
getting rid of that but a good thing was
firebase acquired was acquired by Google
in October 2014 so that was the thing we
looked into and the first step was to
remove the data from the app so that we
could share it across versions so here's
where we have the model for firebase and
at the time we had there was firebase
real-time database when you could access
the same database from an iOS or Android
device would also via the web okay and
the data gets synced in real time so how
do you think we propagated our firebase
real-time database we go back to our
original Google's Google sheet okay and
they're just since I wrote a little
script to take the data from the
spreadsheet and upload it to firebase
okay that's that's an example of just
sending the data from the little excerpt
from the left of code is this what it
takes to send something from one sheet
to the other somebody goes in now and
changes something they added a new thing
it's real-time it shows up in the app
and it syncs over to the firebase
and so this is a little screenshot of
our firebase real-time database the the
firebase real-time database is a no SQL
database which means it's not structured
like in tables like relational databases
are but the big thing now is all the app
data is in the cloud okay and this is a
more recent version but you'll see here
some of the things that we have in here
campus alerts we actually have tutorials
for there that refer to pictures out in
the cloud someplace we have our building
calendars feeds tutorials and then
eventually uses because we incorporated
favorites going on so it gets a little
more complicated and it was actually
pretty easy to set all this up so that
was a big hit a big reason to use
firebase 2 so after that we started
using more of the firebase ecosystem the
key word here was firebase
authentication where people can sign in
by their Manhattan College or Google
email or just a password that
facilitated the development of an in-app
campus ID card and a lot of people to
pin their favorites showed an example of
a the ID card here it basically just has
a barcode whatever and also does a place
where people could add funds to their
their their account actually has a
picture and all that so people were
using this now to swipe in to dorms when
they swiped in the person on the other
we see a picture of the student from the
database in the college and it's to
identify the person and also they were
using it to pay for their meals and
other things it actually it gives them
their balance and whatever it's pretty
immediate when it gets updated and also
here's the thing where they can favorite
their employees and also their favorite
services
from the Algol you search another part
of the firebase ecosystem we started
adopting was cloud fire story that was
in beta ok and that was the little
different model for how the data is
stored part of the problem with using
the real time database was it only
allowed you to use string type of data
and if you want something more structure
the programmers had to write a lot to be
able to to work with that so Cloud
firestore again is a new SQL database
but it's a lot more sophisticated and
allows for more types of data and the
use case for that was a quick view of a
student semester schedule was an
integrated map and instructor directory
ok and here we have when they released a
screenshot where they released my
courses for the string and it actually
shows a student's schedule over here
they haven't yet linked it to the
faculty members profile and also the
building directory
so the firebase document collection for
the cloud fire store is is basically it
consists of a collection with documents
so the way they have a set up is you
have a collection of students so each
each one of these would be a student a
student would have a bunch of
information organized by term first of
all we started doing it for one term and
that's how they initially released it
but their basic students can register
for the next semester at a certain time
and they'd like to see their their
schedule on their phones it was hard to
just display the current semester and
they really need a range of semester and
all that so it's organized by term and
each term would have a student would
have a bunch of classes okay so that's
how that's structured a lot went into
the thinking as to how they wanted to
organize this and the good part was
because we have an iOS developer and an
Apple develop for the two of them sort
of vet things out amongst themselves and
eventually choose the right way to
approach it and this sort of shows it's
hard to shows I was gonna show this on a
timeline but like how the f was
developed over time we started out for
iOS and eventually you know we started
with the Android wanted to sort of play
a little bit of catch-up but because of
how we adopted fire basin and we didn't
have it at the beginning the people
doing the iOS development had to go and
refactor a lot of the code and start
over again because they rip stuff out
whatever the Android person started out
fresh with firebase and all the products
and it has been a very quick evolution
for that and actually he's probably
ahead of the iOS person right now okay
so part of the features we use were we
use the real time database for basic F
data we used authentication for the
gesture card and also favorites and then
cloud fire star for the course schedule
there's all the bunch of other ecosystem
tools in firebase for stability
we have crashlytics crash reporting they
also have firebase test lab which we
used it also has built-in analytics
Google Analytics or fire
rather to show a demo I'm just gonna do
a quickie overview a promotional video
of the app it's sort of quick but we've
introduced this for orientation back in
June
so get students into using the app in
their ID card
[Music]
[Music]
okay so sort of a lot of this sort of
affected where we're going with web and
with applications today we sort of see a
lot of this thing as an app convergence
journey where we'd like to sort of get
these two native apps into sort of one
in some way we're looking at maybe the
firebase cloud functions into helping us
do that we've also started to develop a
lot of web apps and it's electrically to
develop that way and we've been
incorporating them into here by just a
set of links our web application
development stack has changed quite a
bit as a result of mostly how we were
using firebase and there's a lot
different today we're using a lot of
api's different kinds of libraries and
stuff and even being able to run on
nodejs on the google app stack we've
also taken some of these concepts and
have experiments and with a bunch of
google assistant actions the most recent
one is talked to Manhattan College and
this way to extend the assistant and use
the dialogue flow a conversational
action piece to leverage the data from
firebase and the app I'm running out of
time here so I won't show this little
demo again we're using analytics be a
bigquery and data studio to look at some
of the information from the app so this
is a segue into actually learning more
about how we would use cloud SQL to
analyze and bring together other data
sets from the college on a higher level
so in conclusion the firebase platform
has been a great entry point for
integrating with other Google cloud
tools and they've been a valuable
partner in our continual cloud journey
the best part was it was a way for us
all to learn how to develop with some
newest
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]